hey this is Craig Cannon and you're
listening to Y Combinator's podcast
today's episode is with Dalton Caldwell
who's a partner YC in Wamba net who's
the founder of protocol labs a YC
company that's working on ipfs file coin
and coin list if you're just getting
into cryptocurrency I highly recommend
listening to episode 244 of Tim Ferriss
podcast which does a pretty good job of
covering all the terms and explaining
how they all connect to each other and
before we get started I want to let you
know that this is a really long episode
so it's pretty much broken up into three
parts part one starts right after this
and it's ones explanation of ipfs and
file coin part two is our conversation
with Dalton and that starts around
minute 11 and part three is one
answering questions from Twitter and
that starts around 1 hour and 40 minutes
in all right here we go let's just start
with a description of all the words
we've been talking about yet ipfs
protocol labs etc so protocol Labs is a
research development and deployment lab
for networks that I started to really
build the IPS ops project and build file
coin and create a place where we could
create the kinds of projects that you
know could turn into something like a
faster file coin or other other things I
really wanted to build an organization
that you know someone like Satoshi could
have seen as a way to to build a project
through it be like oh yeah instead of
doing this on my own anonymity I could
go and like the open protocol apps and
it is born out of a you know personal
frustration where when I was starting
that defense project I didn't have such
an organization that I could go to and
go and build a project they're really
asking is the only option was either
university or Google and in the
university case it would have been
killed and in the you know publisher
perished world where like hey this is
way too ambitious focus and it's like
one little thing and maybe publish that
and move on to the next thing and it
would have not been an implementation
project you know similar to how the web
could have never really been built as a
grad student project and then the
flipside I think this kind of tech is
stuff that Google might be interested in
in funding from the perspective of
Google funds a lot of protocols and
funds
research but it also kind of runs
counter to basic Google positions around
you know data control of data and how
the internet how information flows and
all that kind of stuff and it's like
hitting direct opposition so it's not
that that probably shouldn't have been
funded or in you know direct control by
Google and it's the kind of stuff that
that I that has the potential to to
really rebalance power on the on the
internet and so you know figured I would
I would start an organizational separate
in the protocol apps is really a group
that is trying to create a number of
these you know projects and protocols
around things that we think are broken
on the internet and kind of like we the
charge that we have for ourselves the
mission that we have is to you know go
and improve and upgrade a whole bunch of
the the software and protocol machinery
that we have running the internet both
you know in low-level actually internet
part or like the web and like more more
users user facing pieces and we have a
very open-ended kind of perspective of
like hey we just want to improve
computing in general and improve the
pipeline of going from research to - to
a product that people use it just
happens that so now and for the next few
years we're super focused on on how
information moves around the internet
how how to distribute it better how to
you know change and rebalance power
associated information give people
sovereignty of data give people and just
make the inner more efficient to make it
you know route around things like you
know attacker and hostile censorship
make it so that you know information has
more permanence a whole bunch of
questions around this and you know the
two projects there are you know one of
them is hype if that's the
interplanetary filesystem it's a used by
a ton of organizations and you know both
businesses and projects and you know
blockchain networks and and governments
and so on and it's used in a whole bunch
of cases around you know it I think in a
short way to describe it because saying
hey it's a
large-scale content addressed content
distribution thing and you know the it's
a protocol it's a peer-to-peer protocol
for moving around anything any kind of
content files data you know hyper media
whatever um in a peer-to-peer way and
you know with proper content dressing
and your cryptographic verification and
all this kind of stuff and a whole bunch
of tooling around the guts of making all
of that work which is peer-to-peer
networks and you know the ability to
work across a whole bunch of different
transports and you know there's no end
to the really important pieces of like
the peer-to-peer machinery that you have
to build that the IPS parts was you know
really about and that's used by a ton of
people both in the blocking space on
outside and it's using the blocks in
space because it fits really well with
the model of like you have authenticated
data structures and you have to you have
hashes and you address things that way
and Sue's outside because people want to
distribute things in a better way people
want to address things by what they are
not where they are like it's really time
it's kind of like it's time for the
internet to move from location
addressing to content dressing and in a
big way we've been I guess appointed to
do so and we have to slog through the
really hard work that is that is doing
that and we're doing it and it's great
and we're committing but you know
there's more to go there's a lot more to
go with what's the current status of
making it all human readable because I
knew that was an issue early on Oh like
a making human readable names yeah so
yeah so human readable names are an
interesting question human readable
names should map to content and people
should use them when they know and are
aware that name is now subject to a
consensus protocol right like in a way
human readable names either require a
consensus protocol to that is global
scale and agree makes everyone agree on
what the value what the value of a name
is or their relative meaning like I
think there's like a gns which is like
the new naming system which is relative
on like a trust graph so you know it
kind of Maps more to how humans think
about names were like you know I might
call a friend Jeremy and I know him as
Jeremy
but in you know he actually might have
last name as well and he might have
other names that he goes by on the
internet and and other people call other
people Jeremy right and so gns it's an
interesting or the approach of using
trust graphs and and so on or social
networks to name people it's a it's a
really interesting and good one
but it doesn't give you the URIs or
names that you can print in a billboard
that a ton of people can look at and
enter into the computer which is the
whole point of human readable naming and
so you know you really are stuck with
consensus and so when you construct with
consensus you either have something
hierarchical like DNS and so on or you
have something like watching naming so
like namecoin or ENS or blocks acts and
you you have a situation where human
real naming is important for people to
type but I think we have like its
massive addiction in human readable
naming where it shouldn't be used in a
lot of places because it brings in a
whole bunch of baggage around hey now
you need a consensus system now you need
like a network stack now you need like a
whole bunch of things that normally you
shouldn't need to just address or point
to some information and so you know we
still want hashes to be the main thing
that people used to link to things just
may be you know allow human readability
as an entry point to all of that okay
huh Julie to describe my opponent first
or do you want to dive deeper okay yeah
so then the Falcon project is a it was
born out of out of ipfs as a way to
incentivize the distribution of content
in the ipfs Network and that's where you
know you think about the problem of
storing bytes of data in the world and
you have a situation where there's a lot
of people with disks and there's a lot
of people with data and it's effectively
a market where people want to buy
storage and some people want to you know
provide storage and provide a valuable
service and so in the you know old
peer-to-peer tradition people would just
resource sharing and kind of try and
hope to achieve like a right balance
it's ensuring that that works for some
use cases but doesn't work for others
and what was really missing there was
like understanding that this is actually
a spectrum where on one end
some people contribute massive amounts
of storage and I'm not and you know
don't really need to use the
than I would very much on the other end
you have people that are contributing or
like you know asking for massive amounts
of sriracha store all their data and
don't plan to contribute any storage and
so this is you know basic like hey
introduce it currency and then now
you've mediated this market and so
that's what popcorn is about is creating
a currency that can mediate this market
now there's a whole second aspect to it
which is you can look at a network like
Bitcoin as an as an entity that I
managed to get tons of people are on the
planet to amass massive like amounts of
computing power to maintain the pickle
and blockchain all of the Bitcoin mining
is going on and can you create a
different proof of work function that
maintains the blockchain that instead of
just you know trying to like crunch
their hashes and find a low target that
also causes a valuable side effect and
that valuable side effect is hey you
have to store a whole bunch of files in
order to you know have power in the
consensus and so a way of framing it is
that the file coin consensus if you want
to participate in the faculty consensus
and maintain the pass on blockchain
what what's counted is not your CPU Rob
power as your as your influence over the
consensus but rather the amount of
storage you are providing to the rest of
the network and so for that we use you
know proofs of storage and specifically
a new kind of proof we came up with we
get discovered which is we call a proof
of replication and so that checks and
verifies that content has been correctly
and independently stored you know
independently in like you know doesn't
mean like different physical hardware
but rather it means that a different
array of bytes somewhere is being used
to sort of this and you can't duplicate
that and that you can't cheat it in that
like you can't generate like you can't
pre generate a lot of the the content
and cheat this we have a very specific
problem but but a the thing there is
following with this different work
function can organize massive amounts of
storage to then sell in the network so
you get a lot of people to mine the
currency and in you know you have a very
strong incentive to mind the currency
and then you can sell all the storage
that supply that comes on
just to users and select up to you know
mediate this this uh it's a blocking
empower decentralized storage network is
the way that we can think about it
take it off what's your first question
so my first question is maybe start with
the timeline of you as a founder what
your initial idea was why you started
the company and just how we got here
sounds good and so it's probably 2013
late 2013 or so I've been working on a
whole bunch of knowledge tools so this
means software tools that can help you
learn faster or help scientists under
like figure out what's in papers and so
on better and I found this really
annoying problem which is datasets like
scientific data sets were not well
versioned we're not well managed and so
on and there's a whole bunch to that
problem but it struck me as this hugely
lacking thing that you know computer
scientists have get and we have
versioning and we also have BitTorrent
and we know how to move around large
large content values of data very
efficiently in a peer-to-peer way and so
what really seem to be missing was the
sort of combination of getting
BitTorrent that would enable these
datasets to be distributed worldwide
well versioned and so on and so that
sent me on a on a on a path of ree-ree
engaging with a whole bunch of stuff
that I'd been thinking about prior like
many years before a lot of peer-to-peer
stuff so I did my background is in
industry assistance and networking I
studied at a Stanford and so at the time
I had then looking into things like
wireless networks and why peer-to-peer
networks like Skype works and so on and
it always taught me that that was a very
untapped area of potential
it just seemed I think the potential
there was a vastly under underutilized
and so all the problems of usability I
don't know if you know my whole
background but my first company I mean
that I started was was a peer to peer it
was it was distributed social networking
and so a lot of these ideas keep
recycling every two years yeah and one
thing that we noticed is how hard it was
for users to get the negative side
effects of having something just having
something that is peer-to-peer
BitTorrent works pretty well but even
Skype Skype kept it really you didn't
know there was unless you're unless
you're upstream bandwidth with
saturating and it got a nasty letter
from your ISP or something you had no
knowledge as a user and so sort of my
takeaway during that era was that
usability always trumped the elegance of
peer-to-peer models and then when I saw
YouTube take off YouTube is exactly the
sort of thing you would expect to be
built on top of BitTorrent but in fact
it was entirely centralized and they
were streaming everything themselves but
holy cow because it worked so well in
flash video work so well
the culmination of those events happened
and so my kind of knowledge going into
this of even for the you know going back
to your story in a second is usability
to me as such as a such an important
concept to have these distributed
systems get used by end-users
absolutely great without a question um
and I mean very I think famously I think
drew Houston has even pointed out how
there were a whole bunch of clunky sync
file-sharing sync things that that like
really just did not work and the big you
know the big thrust of Dropbox for a
while was just get usability right get
the user experience flawless and it
almost as a matter what you do
underneath the hood as long as you as
you make sure the um yeah it is like I'm
sure back in the day everyone's like
well we have our sync that's good enough
you know like we don't need Dropbox we
have our sync right but then there's
like this other fundamental difference
which is that yes absolutely building
these systems is hard and you have to
pay attention to the UX but there's a
whole bunch of places where economically
it makes a ton of sense to do something
better and to do something that has a
different arrangement I think there were
a whole bunch of prop like there was a
period of time basically from 2003 to
2009 or so we're pure appear was sort of
dead and I sort of call it like a
peer-to-peer winter similar to the AI
winter like you know there's been a
series of AI winters that was kind of
like the peer-to-peer winter and there's
probably was where more peer-to-peer
went just before because peer-to-peer is
actually pretty old concept a lot of
people have been been struggling with
the differences between making things
with peer-to-peer or centralized since
the beginning of the internet so I think
there's a whole bunch of reasons why a
lot of the companies failed that were
getting built around that time were
products failed and why they were very
few success stories so I think Skype in
return probably the biggest success
stories were from that entire time and
yeah I think Skype you know didn't
really talk about peer-to-peer very much
yeah and BitTorrent you know slide from
Blizzard and a few others like it was
mostly used for for moving around a lot
of you know movies and so I think that
said though it doesn't like actual CS
behind it like the actual engineering
engineering Ries reasons for choosing to
do something peer-to-peer make a ton of
sense and it's the sections connect very
well with with protocol as a company
because the key thing is to understand
deeply what what the benefits of using
some technology are what are the
underlying you know from like a research
and theory perspective like what is the
theoretical difference between between
doing one thing one way or another like
between centralized models or
decentralized models between doing
things peer-to-peer or doing things in a
hierarchical like well structured way
and and those different properties can
give you a different range of
opportunities now peer-to-peer is a lot
harder to build with because you don't
have a lot of control when you build
centralized things it's a lot easier for
people to get going it's a lot easier
for lots of established ways of doing
things and so on and like rolling out
changes I mean we could enumerate all
these but like when you're going along
it's easy to roll out of website it's
hard to distribute software I mean and
you know one upgrade and I would argue I
would argue that it's easy to roll out a
website today because you're you're
working on top of decades of centralized
so children yeah whereas we haven't had
the same level deep level of engineering
on the peer-to-peer side so the majority
of groups that end up going into peer to
peer end up having to to create a lot of
stuff from scratch because it either
hadn't been done or had been done in a
way that wasn't reusable and this was
actually one of the big threats of the
Antechinus project in general it was
create a whole bunch of oh create a huge
toolkit that people can use to build
applications in peer to peer land
without having to like reinvent
everything from scratch it was like this
really huge frustration for us was like
okay great like it's 2,000
13:14 at the time and we have to go back
and like rewrite tons of normal
peer-to-peer stuff that was you know
could have been written ten years before
mostly because you know the language and
tooling have changed we want to do a few
different things that can reuse a whole
bunch of libraries that we're out there
or the library has made a whole bunch of
assumptions about reality that like
we're we're broken right like um I mean
very famously like I a lot of people
just in from the engineering perspective
you know things like assuming that you
are going to be working on top of TCP
and and the port that you have is a TTP
port and that it's not a UDP port or
whatever or even that you don't have
some other transport right away can make
library completely unusable for a
project like yours on the road I
remember dealing with on that traversal
yeah wonderful problem we filled waves
people ever right let's go back you you
were working on distributed systems this
was interesting to you how did this turn
into the company like what was the thing
you applied to I see with great loads
that go in line there I applied to I see
with with the plan of doing you know
this building both ipfs and sock line
and a company called proto collapse I
mean it was right away from the
beginning it was like this large-scale
plan of going to do build a whole bunch
of different things all around
distributed peer-to-peer systems all of
odd centralization and with the business
model of taking a portion of currency
and this was in 2014 when this was a
very new thing people weren't doing this
there was basically aetherium and a
couple other groups that had also gotten
to the same conclusion and I mean it
aside from a few side projects that we
started and so on and like basically
like delaying our timelines in terms of
like software taking a lot longer to
build an unexpected we pretty much
followed the plan in that it you know
from the beginning we had both ipfs NFL
coin and the the you know I guess
connecting to to what I was saying
earlier so I had this problem around
datasets and versioning and so on and
that led down the rabbit hole of like
really thinking through how information
moves in and then I worked how
information moves on the Internet in the
first place
how does addressing how does it how do
we do addressing in general it turns out
like with HTTP and so on we
we do all this location addressing stuff
that you know works very well for it for
certain kind of use cases but absolutely
terrible for a bunch of other set of use
cases and introduced a whole bunch of
brittleness to to the infrastructure
right and so this this whole like said
about exploring the set of ideas that
had been well trodden by
lots of groups before before me and and
before you know the current wave of
peer-to-peer new mojo nation of course
it was it I was I would run it in my
dorm at Stanford awesome and it had a
lot of the primitives in there right
like I like I ran a node and I had
storage space on my PC and like I had
fashioned it it was great so I I was not
familiar with mojo until I chatted with
Zuko about it and it turns out like mojo
pioneered all this yeah I thought it was
so cool like I thought like I completely
drank the kool-aid and this was in 1999
I was like that was my favorite yeah it
was a great era you had you had in the
beginning of you know Kadena has been
you know the first major large-scale DHD
had been deployed you had a bunch of
people building peer-to-peer networks
like because I which then turn into into
Skype and a whole bunch of other things
and yeah like it was it was very
promising it was like the moment where
everyone was getting connected to the
Internet you can now build like huge
large-scale infrastructure and so on and
it just kind of you know again like
there was is like peer-to-peer winter
like the there's a whole bunch of
reasons why that happened um and you
know people could sit around debating
but I think it had to do with the fact
that the first primary use case that
people were using peer-to-peer for was
copper infringement and that being like
not a viable strategy for a lot of
companies another thing was it was right
around the same time of the rise of the
normal cloud so Google had been Google
and other companies were investing very
deeply into building like large-scale
addition resistance and you know out of
you know they were building hierarchical
structures and they ended up funding and
ton of work down the road in a bunch of
labs so a lot of the labs that we're
doing fear if your research switch
entirely to doing cloud infrastructure
research and so you know that's another
Avenue another point and then I think
probably third or fourth where third was
there was no digital currency so you
couldn't actually pay people correctly
like you had abroad
have trusted you you have the beginnings
of kripacharya like mojo there was a
mojo was the currency as I work
illiterate so you had the beginnings of
digital currencies but they were still
very unproven and still I think rely on
on significant trust in the places so
you didn't have the same same
fungibility that you sorry the same
level of trust with nastain and you
didn't have yeah it's the properties
were not quite there yet with digital
currencies I think another one was just
the the hardware the hardware around
that people had yeah did not warrant a
peer-to-peer structure yet meaning it
made sense for a number of use cases but
a different set of use cases like didn't
make that much sense like it's
interesting to think about you know
computing and normal computing problems
this way because a lot of people always
get hung up on on how things scale but
when you actually think about the total
magnitude of data in a problem sometimes
you realize oh yeah like just throw that
in into one server and like you have one
server and whether you replicate that to
like you have five servers that are all
full copies of the index and like you're
done right like you don't have to build
a very complicated server system to deal
with this because your total amount of
data is way smaller than like the latest
discs right so like whatever I don't
think about this just to put this in
context in a lot of ways history is
repeating itself and the same ideas
cycle back of her Marc Andreessen say
this before that you know Webvan you
know how keep funding ideas that didn't
work over and over again because
eventually it'll work
so instacart a web man so it seems like
a lot of these ideas are well known to
researchers and computer scientists
we're trying them again and there's a
bunch of things that are different you
listed a few of them but to enumerate
them so I understand it's just the tools
are better is that one of them yeah
massively so just the tools are better -
something about the hardware
infrastructure of yeah like bandwidth
plus CPU computing change like just that
you have numbers the actual raw numbers
that people have either just in disks so
it's Moore's Law type stuff yeah okay
well it's not just Moore's law because
you have to account so it's yeah so you
have accelerating returns in you know
computing and storage and and so on and
not so much in bandwidth right so
another so an interesting point to
compare is like realizing that store
decreasing cost super rapidly whereas
been with us not and been with you know
it always feels like the Internet is
really slow because we continue building
larger and larger applications from
larger media but then we can't get to
yeah we can get to the moving around
moving it around as much as sorry wait
say that again we have so there's a
straight up between certain bandwidth
where storages is significantly image
it's getting cheaper at a really rapid
rate where it's an with us not and
because of that what you end up with is
like the feeling that constantly you're
saturating your pipe and that constantly
the internet is slow and so on but
you're just putting a lot more data
through it yeah um and then with is just
not improving as fast and so eventually
we're going to get to a point where it
might actually be cheaper to ship around
stuff to consumers I Drive something
through the internet it's crazy I mean
like already if you if you look at at
how large companies move data they do
not send it over the internet they sent
it over the you know over packages or
move it around physically in some other
way like or direct fibre like something
like if you do data center data centers
transfer you have a direct fiber line
and it's not actually on the Internet
that's right like that's a yeah so if
you have fiber elite yeah if you have
like some really fast you know uplink or
you know some really fast link not
really an uplink because you're in the
core you were the test link between two
data centers and then yeah but like for
simple if you're a company you're trying
to put us on a data into Amazon that was
a little say hey like to ship with a
hard drive and we'll put it on for you
so there's like a so this packet
switching and there's also package
switching
okay so are those the big difference
like I was trying to I did the
enumeration am I forgetting any other
major factor about why this time like
we're running the same play again but
this time it's going to work well I I
don't think this in play I think is
vastly different I think that when you
think about what the projects are trying
to do and what they're building and what
applications are are people are going
for it it's very different so I think
like maybe mojo was like one exception
and like they were really far ahead
thinking about cryptocurrency and
resource sharing and all kind of yeah
because remember was hard drive space
like again as a user
like I get rent out my hard drive space
I could rent out my CPUs like there's
three things
it was bandwidth CPU you earn mojo from
each of those things this rate so if you
think about people like there were a few
people are rounded of time especially
like decipher phones mailing looks like
you can go back and read a bunch of
ideas that have just become reality in
the last few years there were definitely
a lot of people already thinking about
the things that we're doing now but
nowhere close to doing them and so
there's a one big difference between
this wave and the last wave is that is
that the being able to access a range of
applications that were kind of dreams
and ideas back then but we're we're kind
of far away makes this wave actually
quite different in goals right like when
you when you think about few appearances
and one you don't think about mojo that
much you think about Napster you think
about Kazaa you think about you know
those systems that you know BitTorrent
maybe was like the you know it was
actually no tailor and like I turn God
massive and so on but they was like
they're right as a whole bunch of the
other ones we're failing in going away
and so when people think about
peer-to-peer and what was working really
well with peer-to-peer networks at the
time it was mostly pretty simple period
appear structures that you know that
definitely they were like people using
DHCS they were definitely people doing
some amount of like distribution of
files and so on
but it was mostly around like very
simple file sharing problems and it was
so again to summarize the use case
really matters that's what you're saying
so think well I think both the tooling
and the use case that people got to are
very different and like you didn't yet
have smart contracts like you you have
the beginnings of what smart contracts
we're going to be able to do but you
didn't have them in the level of trust
listeners that say it's very amusing
today and that is a very important piece
of infrastructure that wants you once
you deploy something like a theorem a
whole bunch of other things become
instantly possible and which you know it
did not have all the time like you did
not have this kind of you know worldwide
you know a computer effectively that
allows you to run some very expensive
but but trust less code right like you
you don't have to trust the the the
computers running this this this code on
their output right and like you have a
way to verify that all the computation
with them correctly and you call this
concept let's try to use the same
thought experiment there was in there's
infinite demand for free music like I
remember I was I'm exactly the right age
I was in college with Napster cough
everyone there was a product that
everyone wanted yes it was illegal but
there was infinite demand for that what
is the closest analog for the current
generation of things that you think
there's inherent and consumer demand for
um that can drive they can be equivalent
I think it pushes this wave so there's a
lot there because first of all it's not
about consumers ok peer-to-peer wave and
the reason why it's massive is not
because consumer is using it and I think
that's one of the things that Silicon
Valley has failed to understand I think
in 2013 and 14 a lot of the blockchain
tech was being built in New York and
Europe and far ahead of Silicon Valley
and remember we're having a lot of
conversations people here in New York
and Europe and just the level of thought
outside of Silicon Valley was vastly
superior and it was very surprising and
annoying to me because I'm like wait I
was supposed to be the place where like
all of the tech gets developed and so on
and the reality is that it is not that
there was more thinking and that
certainly people in Silicon Valley
understood all of that and have thought
about it and so on but the understanding
about what businesses or what value
propositions might actually be useful in
Silicon Valley was dramatically centered
around consumers and in reality what
what Bitcoin and the theorem did was
allow you to create any kind of you know
financial instrument extremely cheaply
and with you know almost free
verification of correct proceeding of
this financial instrument which is not
normally a consumer need ok well let's
take another like regard to the consumer
part what is that what is the brain
desire need that you think is best
solved but it's not one thing like like
it really isn't well ok we named once
you just talk about five fun oh yeah so
like what is the what is the burning and
it's okay if it's not consumers but what
is the thing that
with file coin that is going to make
whether it's businesses or consumers
people get really excited about using it
and in fact when it's not representative
of the entire industry right like
popcorn is one example with all coin the
the point is being able to so this is a
whole different argument that I think is
is make sense with or without a
peer-to-peer winter or summer like the
fact the thoughts around popcorn are
about thinking about the massive latent
source that's out there and putting it
to good use right like there's there's
exabytes of Surak they are not in use
right now and that if you were to add
them to the to the market you would
drive the price down significantly and
so I think like trying to end up strew
whether or not there is currently a
peer-to-peer wave or whether or not
people are excited about peer-to-peer in
any way or decentralization and now
there's there's a point that you can
build a network like PowerPoint that can
use the centralization and can use
financial assets created
cryptographically to then organize a
massive group of people are on the
planet to then do this right and I think
you just look at so before getting all
of the the excitement around
centralization just think about Bitcoin
as a way to incentivize people to add a
bunch of hardware to a network there's
been nothing like it it generated a
massive massive amount of you know
computing power dedicated to do one
single thing which is you know try and
and find fine hashes that are low target
and and you have tens of thousands of
people around the planet that were that
worked really hard to add a bunch of
hardware to this and you end up with
this insane hash rate that is you know
when you actually work out like the
amount of power and computation that
it's using it's like one of the one of
the most powerful computer networks in
the planet and so when you take that
idea of you saying saying create a very
strong financial incentive for people to
do something around the planet and you
then couple it with building some other
kind of resource sharing Network
something something like Fah storage you
can organize this massive massive
network as well and you can put all of
that Lane source that already is there
and depreciating and going to waste into
valuable use and so so far kinds of
business around
you have to think about these these
networks are as services and businesses
that are solving some set of problems
but it's not a which is one problem
that's a thing fundamentally different
about this this type of saying than
normal consumer products
well they solve a lot of problems for a
lot of people you said financial though
so like again they're doing it for a
financial reason so again what I'm
looking for is what is the incentive for
someone to get involved whether it's a
business or consumer so it's it's the
reason you would put a minor on the
network for a file point specifically
the reason why somebody would add
storage the network the primary
motivator will be money that's what's
going to drive this massive amount of
storage now a secondary and very
important motivator is also the fact
that like data is completely
centralizing the whole bunch of
providers and we get a lot of businesses
and and people highly concerned about
this that we want to distribute our data
across a number of providers and one
stronger guarantee they want a different
set of features but you don't
necessarily need the peer to peer to to
achieve that that just happens to come
with the package right and so I think
for for you think about Bitcoin miners
and you can you can think about the the
motivations of Bitcoin miners are not
you know fundamentally about just
enabling peer-to-peer and so on there
the huge motivator there is money now it
that's not true of the early Bitcoin
miners right the early become miners a
lot of them were were primarily
motivated by building a digital currency
that was not controlled by any
government and that's something very
different than what we have today we
have today is is a structure where it's
a massive business and people are like
going for it and select ups that's you
know I think fundamentally different but
but it doesn't make sense to try and
like box it in to say like hey there's
one thing that the entire industry is
trying to do like in fact when it's like
completely different than the entire
inch it's like we're using things from
the industry to create a very powerful
service but and the reason I mentioned
financial instruments is because that is
the fundamental information innovation
that both pay for interfere might reduce
the ability to create financial
instruments extremely cheaply without
spending tens to hundreds of thousands
of dollars instead you know writing a
few lines of code and you don't have to
litigate this in court if it goes wrong
it just automatically automatically
settles in a computer and so it's
with what happened with what the
blocking stuff is that software began to
eat finance and law in a way that had
never happened before there were a whole
bunch of things that we're kind of
waiting or like a lot of ideas that
people had had for for a long time some
of them you know a few years some of
them decades that got knocked loose by
the existence of a digital currency that
was ludicrous and suddenly a ton of
these applications were being able to be
built so it's it's a very different
thing than than than the early
peer-to-peer time the fact that that
ipfs platform happened to relate a lot
to the early period of pure goals is a
side effect the majority of the watching
world does not care at all about those
early goals they care about different
goals they care about a different kind
of the central decision the
centralization of power not of resources
so fast what happens to care about the
centralization of resources and
distribution and like use in all kinds
of but it's a very different different
thing how are people incentivized with
mojo to like put their put their drives
online um you would get low Joe is the
name of the current whatever is tokens
wasn't you would get you would earn mojo
and you could spend it on other stuff
and they were very vague about that you
could spend it on other storage okay and
what's in my query but yeah
in the same way yeah it was kind of like
when Rick Bitcoin very first came out it
was sort of like a cool thing on slash
dot right it wasn't like a serious
project and what was interesting is
people here and um people what people
spent a lot of time doing blackhat stuff
to try to earn more like it was very fun
yeah to try to get more yeah I think a
lot of people like I used to read the
commit list and a lot of people a lot of
what they had to write was anti hacking
stuff what you would expect you know
good someone with a hacking brain
whenever they see new stuff it's always
fun to try to take advantage of it yeah
cool so what do you what do you think
this is sort of an aside but I read I
read YC applications for all this stuff
and I I'm trying to understand what the
best use what do you wear do smart
contracts help you
it's a founder this is a little bit
outside of the ipfs thing but
what is the use case that in its current
state are most useful for smart
contracts because I see a lot of people
applying with these and I've yet to see
one with a non conceptual use case so is
there a case in your business where you
would use smart contracts you can think
of popcorn as a smart contract whether
or not it's implemented as a smart
contract on top of the theorem or not
yeah you can think of the idea of a
protocol declaring what the rules of a
financial transaction it's going to be
and a very clear cryptographic way of
you know proceeding through that
transaction and verifying it at the end
like that's effectively it's my contract
it might not be whether you you know you
can think of Bitcoin the whole thing as
a smart yeah yeah I mean like I feel in
the metaphor I'm just I'm thinking of
like the part where we eat the financial
world unlike what you're seeing you're
seeing you know super you can go today
and start writing a something that
behaves like equity or something that is
derivative or you know all of these
kinds of financial instruments that
would take you a ton of time to kind of
think about and reason about it and like
inject into into the jurisdiction you
know any kind of legal jurisdiction in
the world and you're now able to do that
in a totally different way with a whole
bunch of assets of represent real value
and so like I think that there's a ton
of these that have very direct use cases
and applications but they're not they're
not consumer and and so that's that's
why you're seeing a wave of things that
seem weird to Silicon Valley they seem
like all this would never work and yet
there's a ton of companies out there in
the world that actually need these kinds
of things that actually think you're
like oh wow like that means I don't have
to spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars and millions of dollars in legal
just to understand reason about and
conduct these transactions and then have
to worry about litigation down the road
of like in the millions of dollars to
try and make sure the transaction is
safe you can then turn that into into
like single dollars right of like
running transaction fees and like is
that is a massive shift and we haven't
even begun to see the the options of
that like there's in the beginning so
there's like you can you see a ton of
assets being
creator in ethereum that have a bunch of
different kinds of properties but
they're they're fundamental like these
kinds of assets you know it's actively
like you get to create any kind of
financial instrument you want as long as
you can reason about how to program it
and you can deploy it into the network
and so you can solve a whole bunch of
these kind of problems one interesting
example is insurance right so like you
can do insurance trivially on top of a
theorem like there's I think a really
fun one that you know I've get used it
because like I my perception on a lot of
these things like maybe insurance is an
interesting consumer one actually so an
insurance policy is a very simple idea
there's a whole bunch of regulation in
the regular you know jurisdictions when
you think about how to insurance
quality's work but you can definitely
create structures and financial
structures around ensuring some activity
and so there's a contract out there
where you can tell it your flight and
you can buy an insurance policy for a
few either and it pays out like if you
if you if you miss a flight gets delayed
then it pays you up pay some out some
amount if the flight gets canceled it
pays out some of them and all that can
happen by just writing a few you know a
few dozen lines of smart you know it may
be hundreds of lines with absolutely and
it needs some sort of Oracle that brings
in the the real-world data of of the
flight and once you have that you're set
and you can now create insurance policy
so I think I think this was I'm know
exactly who built it but there's it was
a effectively trivial project and you
now have what normally would take a
company of dozens to hundreds of people
like reasoning about all of the legal
landscape around insurance and how to
provide this and then like legal
protections of how to make sure that
goes correctly and how do you collect
and things and like just all of that
madness go the way completely by
replacing it with where the same smart
contract right and so I think those are
the kinds of things to start seeing and
there's a big bottleneck right now which
is that you know the fundamental
innovation is one around so that let me
rephrase this because it only gets
characteristic of the entire entire
space one of the fundamental innovations
have something like aetherium is this
decreasing you know software heating
finance and
law and when you can create these
contracts and financial instruments
really fit really a whole bunch of
things open up and so so far the people
that have waited through the difficulty
in using these platforms to do this
happen to be people that are looking at
large-scale transactions like things
that that would otherwise require a lot
of money to do or things that suddenly
become possible to do in this space of
crypto assets and they're just kind of
transplants of the regular world they're
looking at some way of doing some
transactions in the regular world and
they say wouldn't it be great to do that
with ether and then they go on build it
what you're going to start seeing in the
near term is that there's this blocker
around user experience where right now
nobody can use these blocks Ian's
systems from normal consumer devices and
with the same kind of UX that people
expect so there's a massive barrier
there where a ton of applications that
can be geared towards consumers right
like so so instead of starting from a
consumer need or rather instead of like
the entire space solving consumer needs
now you can create something that now
solves some important consumer need
right now it cannot get deployed easily
and it cannot take off because the UX is
so hard to get right and you have you
know every individual project has to
spend an enormous amount of resources
thinking about the the UX of the users
like one great example of this is open
Bazaar a great project like you're
building like it is completely
decentralized eBay type thing and they
allow buyers and sellers to come in and
and and you know buy and sell things and
so when the project started they had to
build all their peer-to-peer stack we'd
like from from the ground up and like
that was a huge undertaking for them
then they found you know at the same
time we were building IPO fastnesses
atonic profess and you know it made a
lot of sense for them to switch over to
epic hudson and they did that and so
like that hopefully saved it'll save
them a lot of time in the lower layers
but then they have to go and build all
of the UX side of things and so they had
an application that you can download and
locally but then you know think about
thinking about mobile you now have to
think and build a mobile application and
get people the same kind of utility like
that that is yet another massive
undertaking and they're doing it like
it's I'm super impressed like we have
this this awesome mobile app that you
know I think I don't know if it's out
yet but it's going to
it's super exciting like like I think
it's one of the very first things in the
entire space that like gives you like
the really nice you know normal us you
would expect in normal product and you
know the entire space has to catch up so
I think it's going to take about a year
or two before you start seeing these
things get mainstream consumer use it
could happen faster without a lot of
these things you know maybe it's one
library white right like somebody writes
a really solid library that kind of
solves a bunch of the problems and then
everything gets easy but you know just
because you you're not seeing a ton of
consumers consumer use things yet does
not mean they aren't about the hit in a
huge way but that's what I wanted to
focus on before because you kind of you
kind of like just juxtaposed like 2013
2014 like people not really getting it
here things not being built here
obviously in 2017 things have changed
right like what has changed in like
what's motivating people now to start
building these things because I wonder
like you know we have a lot of founders
listening and they're like trying to
figure out the ideas like what's needed
what what change to make this possible
what seem to make what specific possible
because a lot of yeah okay so one one
trajectory is like okay why is San
Francisco into this now and then the
other is like what change to like start
pushing for obviously aetherium came out
but then like all these products are
following as well I think San Francisco
Silicon Valley got interested when the
ICO craze happened when you suddenly
have projects raising ten you know
twenty thirty five hundred million
dollars suddenly everyone was like what
the hell is going on what's happening
and it was actually the money that was
the the thing that drew attention and as
I don't know I think that's pretty short
sighted I think the the underlying
differences or like the underlying hard
foundational work that you know people
are seeing like reaping the benefits
right now like all of that that creation
of value and so on happened over the
last two years with aetherium which was
a project that here was seen as like
this crazy science project thing that
like was never going to work and would
like to crazy and so on and was this
regarding completely by tons of people
and they just
fail to do the deep thinking of like
looking at these these very contrarian
perspectives and contrarian ideas that
like dared to question underlying basic
assumptions about consumer products
today which is that nobody really cares
about giving your data to everyone
nobody really cares about trust nobody
really cares about just like running
these kinds of transactions everyone has
you know some easy way to to use a
mobile app everyone trusts Google
Facebook Apple Amazon everyone B or
whatever and it's really just about
convenience and if you don't have
something that's convenient
screw it it doesn't design ever going to
work and and that was like just false
like I think that perspective you know I
don't mean to characterize entire valley
that way I think there were a ton of
people thinking very deeply about what
bitcoin was going to do to the world and
a lot of people invested very heavily
into Bitcoin and creating Bitcoin
companies and that's you know turn out
in a number of ways really well in
another case not so well but I think
what can be said about the whole space
is like we're seeing projects emerging
that are about building large-scale
infrastructure that might take years to
build out before the utility is shown
and that's just something that normal VC
can't entertain like VC is not built for
long term investments in things that are
extremely high risk and building some
deep foundational technology VC is tuned
for ten-year returns which means that in
two three years you have to like show
very strong you know sign of like
massive adoption and are really strong
business which means that if something
is more than two years out in
development and there's research
questions to be solved it doesn't fit
and so you have to go and figure all
that before historically it wasn't the
government that funded all this stuff
that's right so so one of the and this
is you know part of why and building
collapse which is that there's this
massive gap between this is huge open
area where like stuff is not getting
funded around
yeah building large-scale infrastructure
like you couldn't might my claim as you
couldn't build something as free and
open and that works as well as the
internet today because no group would
fund it and and what you would end up
with is a massively stunted version of
something that is highly centralized and
controlled by a couple by a couple of
groups and that wouldn't have the the
amazing generality of something like
tcp/ip like part part of what's
beautiful about tcp/ip a DNS like that
whole era of protocols was that people
worked super hard for months and years
at a time to think about the interfaces
and refine it so that you could end up
with something sufficiently abstract to
support us on that use cases and
sufficiently concrete to actually work
today and that kind of development is
not super fast and takes a lot of work
and takes a lot of money and that's not
something that you know VC funds VC
funds clear applications or wise why
would why should VC like in those cases
those are done by brain universities
right and bail at like the those things
exist today it's mostly doing AI stuff
but like the closest equivalent to that
are things like open AI or Google brain
and all that where like there's
absolutely no practical use of that
stuff but man there's a lot of money in
grant research know practically Google
brain they're not productizing
immediately uh Vasiliy very firmly i
think that that a very clear use for
Google brain is massive cuts reductions
to a company like Google yeah I mean I
guess I can speak much more comfortable
opening I could actually know how that
works and like there's not we're not
like productizing but you see a lot of
stuff being rolled in like
speech-to-text already yeah but it's
like again it's not a startup like
there's no bottom there's no double
bottom line where people are trying to
monetize like that's not why it's being
funded so you saying like if you want
people working on this foundational
stuff it seems like if you're trying to
replicate what you feel like worked
really well do you think it needs to be
direct does the does the analog need to
be directly replicated or any other it
these council projects don't get funded
and when you could see it with something
like SpaceX and Tesla SpaceX and Tesla
both went through major major funding
issues right
if Elon hadn't been
they're finally wealthy both projects
would have probably failed yet and and
here you know you that is a clear
example of something that is you know
it's basically maybe not directly you
know consumer perspective but Tesla
definitely right like definitely it's a
very consumer oriented thing but it was
extremely difficult it was a large-scale
long-term project that just you know
scared the hell out of VC with good
reason like it's extremely unlikely that
you would get any of that to work but
what I'm highlighting is not that
necessarily BC has to fund this what I'm
saying is that that's not what VC funds
and because that's not what VC funds and
then there is no you know no strong ARPA
like organizing major large-scale
infrastructure endeavors like it used to
then you have this gap and this hole of
things that weren't getting funded and
and the lab is a great example like I
part of the reason that I started Burke
lab is to try and recreate kind of the
spirit of of the labs in in an
organization at least focused around
around networks and and the only a bit
of reason that you had something like
Bell Labs happening was because you had
an entity that was very enlightened this
perspective about technology and
understood how to innovate and
understood how how large-scale
innovations could be done and with deep
investment over decades right likely
they would run projects for multiple
decades like sometimes they would break
up projects and like you know here's
like these first five years going to be
about this the next five years ago about
this sort of thing and so on a curiosity
it wouldn't see a product until much
later do you know what their budget was
if we translated it to modern dollars I
don't know what the budget is like tens
tens to hundreds of billions or more it
was it but then you but then you figured
it out with a cerium right because the
value gets accrued to the people that
are creating and developing the protocol
there's a fundamental shift yes and so
but I think something a bit different I
want to draw an analogy between what
happened at the labs in Google brain so
Bell Labs was about constructing massive
cost reductions for Bell so the reason
that labs got to thrive as an
organization was because it represented
a very strong financial interest for
this massive monopoly that had an
enormous business and so they had deep
pockets to just invest deeply into into
things that we're going to save them a
lot of money later
and so bail could look at things like oh
wow you know vacuum tubes are really
inefficient or vacuum tubes break a lot
and it's a huge pain to repair them
wouldn't it be great if we had something
better and it basically took something
like 20 years I think it's like 10 to 20
years before before the transistor right
and it's something like I might be wrong
in those states but the point is Bell
Labs understood the need Bell Labs of
this massive cost reduction that
happened and it says how did that's one
of the open problems and so if you were
researcher the lapse of time one of the
things that you could work on that was
seen as kind of you know a very
important problem salt was replaced
vacuum tubes create something that can
replace vacuum tubes and it took a whole
bunch of open-ended thinking and you
know deep fundamental research in from a
physics perspective and solid-state
physics and you know just like the story
of Shockley and Burdine and and britain
and so on
to be able to come up with something
that became the transistor that solved
that problem but that was an innovation
that happened over you know decades and
timescales and primarily motivated by
cost reductions on the large scale Bell
front and so the the funding that Bell
could feed into funding tens to hundreds
of researchers thinking about all these
problem the specific problem on it on a
ten year time horizon to try and get
that kind of like cost reduction is
something that only massive monopolies
today have been able to fund it's like
basically massive monopolies either in
business or in touring or in power right
so it's either massive monopolies like
Bell or Google or massive monopolies
like the US and in power of being able
to say we need something that connects
all the computers around and we just
needed so like just fund it whatever the
space race or the space race right like
we need to we need to get to the moon
like but I don't care how much money you
take it's just like make it happen right
and so so that kind of directed power
and funding can can predictably innovate
like which is kind of amazing like you
can you you in velocity had a a place
where they could
chart out the things that they were
working on and kind of think through
when they were going to not exactly
impersonate per year but like they would
know the relative progress through a
whole bunch of open-ended problem that
whose solutions ended up gaining people
giving people Nobel Prizes right like
this was the kind of innovation that
that is seen but and recognize that the
world is like this stroke of genius that
that you know would have been so hard
and so unpredictable and so on
and yet the labs was able to like
reliably get a whole bunch of
researchers to to achieve these kinds of
innovations and so that unfortunately
like the model of why Bell Labs the
question is around why the labs
ultimately failed and fell apart have to
do more with the surrounding ecosystem
like its funding source cuz I want a
better way broke apart monopolies that's
right so so breaking bail apart
effectively cycles and killed Bell Bell
Labs so a few things happened one was
the rise of Silicon Valley and the great
invention or invention but like the
great use of stock options or just
giving stock to to everyone in the
company working on something cause a ton
of people working on very you know
research fee oriented things at the time
to become quite wealthy right or like
get you know very significant personal
returns and that coupled with the
excitement around all of the stuff that
was happening in Silicon Valley in the
50s and 60s with you know a number of
people kind of moving out and then
coming back and talking about all the
great and exciting things that were
happening in the West started to drain a
lot of people out of the labs and out of
Boston and so this you know known as
it's like brain drain and part of that
what what happened there was not only
were people leaving and going and
creating other research organizations
that had different funding models but
that also started getting broken up and
this is more like the 80's 90's I forget
except the exact date on this but when
when Bell got broken up Bell Labs had to
find a way to like charge the you know
new separate entities for all of its
work and it just became infeasible to
fund and maintain a massive organization
like that and so I don't end up breaking
apart so there's a few like interesting
financial reasons why
labs didn't couldn't continue existing
but the research organization itself was
amazing and continued to be amazing for
a very long time now so yeah so
according to one site their budget was
500 million in 74 which translates to
1.5 billion today or two percent of ATS
gross revenue 1 billion so in 1 minute
yeah I wanted to have million so yeah I
was like yeah all right so I was like
tours minded off so exceda something
like 10 to 100 that's a lot better that
it's a lot cheaper than than what I
expected like foundational research due
to cost but that's still massive right
like being able to - I guess on the on
the scale of 10 years like yeah that's
10 billion right ok you you have to have
10 to 50 billion and ready to commit
them for like two decades to be able to
undertake some of these projects yeah
probably self-driving cars is getting
that kind of money today probably AIG in
that kind of money today there's a few
things that maybe if you added all the
R&D budget being put into it or getting
that but it's definitely not well ladies
I think I think something like Google
brain is a clear example of this kind of
thing happening again where where Google
saw massive advancements in machine
learning we want to apply all of those
massive advancements to image to machine
learning into a whole bunch of the
normal Google applications and we want
all of our applications to get better
faster stronger and so on and reduce
costs and not only are we going to be
able to do a whole bunch of new things
and cool things but we're also going to
be able to do them a lot cheaper which
gives us which effectively is making
money right so like the thing to think
about is once you're an organization
that's big enough you don't have to sell
more products to make money you just
have to cut your cost and then make sure
I understand you're saying that is
analogous to the Bell Labs model that is
I'm just making sure I'm yeah so I I
wouldn't want to claim that something
like Google brain or or even acts is
akin to to Bell Labs because I think
that's a very different research are
very different organizations I think
that the Google brain and acts are are
much more focused on on shorter term
valuable things than the labs I think
both brain and X can't yet afford to
innovate on the multi decade timescale
they're they're innovating in like
single decade time scales
their own I wouldn't I think that you
know if you look around the planet
there's a closest thing probably you
know very cut they're still kind of far
away and I think it'll take you know
much more not only capital but also like
reach of that organization to be able to
like undertake some of these larger
scale fundamental like when you start
seeing Google funding open-ended physics
research labs like then then then we're
in the four decade or more for a decade
or more like there's a budget a minute
yeah where you see it the budget of a of
a Google run physics lab have a you know
budget for a decade or more and like 50
plus researchers and you know you start
seeing some noble prices one out of
Google like then then we're talking
about the same thing but we're far away
from that and I think the the I don't
think well we don't necessarily to
recreate the same kind of structure I
think what we can do is is look at a
different thing that's going on and look
at how innovation happens in a very
different open-ended way in in the
internet so the Internet has a lot of
similarities with the research culture
of that labs in that it's extremely open
you get a lot of people thinking about
problems you you have a lot of people
talking about problems and discuss not
only talking about potential solutions
but trying them out and so on and so the
people sharing knowledge and ideas for
the internet and working and open in
other groups has been able to have very
important results achieved but they're
of a very different nature like you
don't get something like that transistor
out of out of you know random open
source collaboration you get something
like Bitcoin aetherium which are
arguably like in like the Linux kernel
like just use they're very different
yeah but like that's a case for the
internet right the Linux kernel that
exists cuz the Internet yes the Linux
kernel is an awesome example I think
like you have the ability to to
undertake these major major
infrastructure projects and like things
that take a long time to to create a
mature on the internet and a whole other
interesting Avenue here is how do you
fund these things like how do you how
can you fund these long term endeavors
that are much more open-ended and on the
internet and so on and that's what
Bitcoin and aetherium proposed one
example of how you fund that and this is
this goes back to what you were sorry to
bring up earlier which is the idea of
you have a protocol and you have you
take that protocol and you say hey it's
going to create a whole bunch of value
and it also has this this native token
that's going to address a whole bunch of
that value not all of it but some subset
and that native token is going to be of
limited supply so because we were
creating this token we can take some of
that token and give it to the people
building the protocol which then helps
you know they can sell it for dollars or
whatever to then feed themselves and
then that way they can like actually
fund the development of the project and
this is effectively what would a theorem
did right so that kind of funding model
allows people to remain very close to
the the actual protocol layer and to
think deeply about the protocol itself
and his concerns without having to think
about a product or a service on top so
this is precisely what protocol app is
business model is and how do we keep the
funding going on because obviously
there's a certain amount of hype and
excitement right now with all the ICS
happening
oh yeah I mean like there's there's a
ton of stuff happening right now I mean
I think I think we get over ten years
like let's like well that's like drill
down to because that's a great point
we're just talking about it what's the
tenure like how do you you have to keep
selling bits not you personally but if
you're one of these folks do you have to
keep constantly reissuing tokens to keep
feeding yourself I mean if it depends on
whether another token appreciates right
say the token appreciates enough then
you're gonna have to sell less and less
of it over time yeah so you saw this
happening with Bitcoin I mean there are
people there were some people that were
early to bitcoins that are are now you
know they have their their personal
wealth at a point where you know unless
it wasn't major crashing their asses
like they don't have to work again yeah
and you know they kind of ten years old
now almost right so it's sort in 2008
doesn't that look like yeah
and so like you know it's roughly ten
years old and yeah I mean I think I
think maybe you could claim that the
origins of Bitcoin happened through the
sacrament lesson motor nation
and all these other things and all those
discussions and so that was like
long-term innovation that happens and
then only was getting funded afterwards
so it's like you know very different
approach than say the Bell Labs you know
centralized perspective but yeah I think
the funding of these things it's going
to depend entirely on whether these
things are continued to be useful right
so if here we continue to be useful five
ten years from now you're going to have
and continues to accrue goodies to grow
right to the etherium becomes more and
more successful continues to solve a
whole bunch of problems then an ether is
going to be worth a ton more and as that
ether is worth a lot more yet you're now
going to have you know tens of thousands
of people that right now are crypto
millionaires turning into you know ten
million they're going to have 10 million
100 million potentially billionaires who
knows right like I don't know I think at
that point like you the valuation of
something like material gets yes as high
as something like Google and Apple and
so on and who knows maybe it's maybe it
is worth that but I don't think it's
quite quite there yet but you know you
have this very different way of building
a service where you take a share of the
worth of the service in a sense like
having ether it's kind of having a share
of the worth of network there's not the
worth of the network totally the network
is worth more than that but it is a
subset of that and then you can you know
if you choose to hold it then in a
cruising value then you have now gotten
a return and so it's risky like you know
definitely it would not encourage anyone
to to invest so deeply into
cryptocurrencies that they have you know
a very significant fraction of their
other you know the during the dot-com
bubble everyone was a day trader and
everyone mate you couldn't lose
it actually if you would have bought and
held to this day and you were lucky
enough to have enough exposure to what
like Apple and Google it actually
would've been okay but if back in a your
day trading and you didn't have one of
those big winners or if you just lost
all your money in the early days you
know if you just sold early if you just
sold early it would've been rough but
it's it's kind of tricky right now
because it's really hard to lose money
there's a very big you know kind of
honeymoon period right now yeah a ton of
people are have just finally understood
the massive value that can be generated
by these things and the excitement is
around and everyone is really stoked and
I mean if you if you caught Google and
you invested early on like if you were
one of the early investors great during
the height of the bubble right like or
PayPal or any of these amazing companies
that got built or that period I guess
actually give me not Google didn't go
out 204 so I stand corrected I'm trying
to think of a 99 who could you have
caught like a viewer day trader
definitely Apple yeah but I wouldn't
think of this like day trading and IPO
markets like you have to think about
this are you it's the same thing where
this popular media was like hey you
could buy this stock and make 3s it's
more of like people are like if you
invested that way you probably ended up
getting you know stuck into throne' to
the bubble line like you you probably
lost that money but if you helped I'm
making argument if you would have held
and you had a decent portfolio then you
actually even if you were the dumbest
money at the top of the market you would
have done okay yeah maybe another is
like you could say right is that maybe a
question like do you apply like an ETF
model right now and just buy some of
everything and yeah I'm kind about like
right like one of the learnings is yeah
go ahead I think the more important
thing that's going on deeper which is
that a whole bunch of important things
are getting built and you can if you
find them you can fund them and you can
be part of them and can help create them
and create massive massive value and the
people that do that are going to get
greatly rewarded and I think that goes
along with diligence like you can't just
approach I think my perspective on this
and the way that I look a lot of the
spaces is that I think deeply about each
of these pieces of the penalty and I
approach it much more like investing
into into a startup or investing into a
project that I think it's worthwhile and
should happen even if I lose out all
money that I invest in it
and I think about the underlying value
that's being created like what what is
this thing going to enable in two five
ten years from now you know I think
within the craft of space you you don't
even need to think to in ten years I
just you do a resigner question that
that's a little different though than
basic research like is it part of basic
research you don't want you want to
believe that the researchers are good
but you don't actually want to worry
about
what they're working on because they're
going to do great stuff do you know I'm
saying this isn't mean I go through when
I'm looking at these it's like you want
to understand that it's a good team and
you believe in their vision but if you
get too in the details yet you'll like
miss the boat right okay and then think
alike so we're making mixing so many
we're basically so many different topics
which is awesome by the way I rarely get
to get to get this deep into into a lot
of conversation a lot it I just I don't
mean to imply Bitcoin or theorem is like
that laughs it's like a different thing
it's like a different thing that that is
showing off that or what you get out of
it is you can see innovation of the kind
that you saw at something like that labs
happening in the open Internet with
people exchanging ideas with people like
scrounging and funding and whatever the
way they can until later and like now
that we have cut the currency now when
you fund a model can emerge and now we
can trust thinking about this in a
deeper way so when I think about
structuring Vella sorry when I think of
structuring about protocol labs you know
we think about flatpoint as a specific
service and business that has a much
shorter term perspective it's like
Lachlan has to work and be successful
and valuable in two three years not five
or ten and we're nowhere near close to
be able to clear 83 we're in so it is
five years in you already the company's
in two or three years interest yeah yeah
so it is we're building activist first
right so so ipfs is out there and
creating a ton of value for visuals but
a bit because it's not something that we
plan to monetize directly like I
professor is a large-scale
infrastructure project that happens to
be at a layer where you should not put
money like money should not go and be a
question on moving data money should be
a concern that's applied on top to a
subset of those transactions and so it's
all sort of those protections are the
going to be the platform transactions
and now we're building out we're setting
off and doing all this work so it's a
yes I think I think you know it really
started the clock on on Falcone and
we've had a whole bunch of like detours
right like we've had you know we ended
up building this whole platform called
coin lists so you can you can go in and
and have token sales and so on because
like that whole madness of how do you
correctly and legally do a token sale is
a you know huge rabbit hole probably
sure you know that there's a whole hour
on that we
but you know we built a platform that
allows people to to do that in a
compliant way in the u.s. using you know
set of documents that we've developed
called the saft similar to the safe but
for tokens and so on and like that was a
detour circlex like you know for six
months of like work but it can end up
being super viable for the entire rest
of the ecosystem and four perk labs in
that we will have not only pokémon but
other products on the road that we'll
end up using coin lists and you know
longer-term investment you're like
invest a little bit deeper into the
thing and now you have it and so like
you know Franklin has been delayed by
ipfs and its success and by things like
coins and so on all right now we're like
we've managed to successfully switch
gears to go and lay invest very deeply
into the whole into the whole thing one
of the most interesting things probably
about path on that you'll see coming out
very soon is we spent about a month and
a half
rethinking the entire protocol from
scratch and and looking at it in you
know looking at all the advancements
that have happened in the service
systems in crypto and
the blockchain space in general in the
last two three years since the paper
came out and and just like we got to
upgrade all over the entire system while
it's still in and you know before it's
out and live and people are using it and
it's being a very different protocol
right so we're about to like ship the
the new files on paper and it's a very
different particle and then when you
when people first saw it has solves a
whole bunch of important problems and we
had for a brief period of like you know
a month and a half something akin to
like a Bell Labs feel of like four or
five people in a house doing nothing but
reading papers and working on on card
research problems and reading the papers
of like Turing Award winners and then
like being a step ahead of some of them
and being like oh wow they just
published this thing and like that's a
problem that we talked like well ago or
something and that was like a you get
like glimpses of this happening right
and like you can think of someone like
metallic as operating entirely in that
in that space where he's just thinking
about large-scale problems in the 5 10
year time horizon to creators Aryan yeah
but I like Batali the creator of
etherium and he he is
managed to build for himself a lab
similar to one you would have at a place
like like Bell Labs or something but in
a very different landscape right and I
think this is you probably won't see
that the creation of a labs like the one
before it's possible that someone like
Google and so on creates it but I think
what we'll have instead is is a much
more distributed version of it where you
will have smaller labs that are able to
like get large-scale tenure time prize
and funding and what I'm particularly
interested in and you know kind of like
throw this out there now because it's an
interesting problem that I think is
worth solving and if we solve this like
you can have massive implications for
the world like here's a you know your
researcher and you and you want to think
about like not just starting businesses
and starting companies and so on but
like really think deeply about what what
kind of problems do we help them today
would have would create like enormous
value for humanity worldwide there's a
very specific problem in in this like an
economics problem it's the it's also an
AI problem it's the credit assignment
problem which is that if you have a set
of agents that are participating in a
set of endeavors and those endeavors
either create or destroy value how do
you correctly propagate reward back to
the agents meaning you know if you have
a number of people working on a start-up
and you create a whole bunch of value in
the startup and that ends up you know
can't you capture some of that as a
reward how do you propagate the reward
back effectively this is equity equity
right now is like the way that this is
done in a larger scale in the market is
seen as investments and capital and you
know the the capital formation world and
so on but then when you look at it in a
different world in science for example
you have labs that are effectively
accruing academic credit and and and you
know social kind of academic social
credit and credibility that they're
going to be able to use to then get
further grants to fund the rest of the
thing and look that's a different answer
and when you think about open source we
don't have today an easy way of
correctly figuring out and computing
what is the credit assignment on
something like the Linux kernel right I
mean Linux has done an enormous amount
of work
and and you know created a huge fraction
of the value from the Linux kernel but
so have a ton of other people that have
been you know slogging and waiting
through major major issues and the
majority of those people that are
building this huge foundational thing
that is now on like you know a huge
fraction of the computers in the planet
did not see any kind of kind of reward
attributed to them on the scale of the
companies that came after that user
technology and captured value right so
you can see something like Android as
capturing massive amounts of value that
went into the Android business and
Google and and you know all of those
those groups that completely rode on the
on the value created by the Linux Linux
kernel group and you can think about
this across every single business every
single business that runs computers in a
large scale like has been he has gotten
value out of the Linux kernel grip and I
mean how can we just like propagate
reward back so that you know all of
those people now no longer have to like
worry about like other data I think you
know like really just focus on this
thing but can you do this in a you know
in a big scale across all possible you
know
projects right so we are super
interested in solving this problem
because we think if we solve this
problem you know even if we have like a
bit of a good answer to this problem
then we can fundamentally change how
open-source gets built in that it would
be great if people that are working on
work on projects and open source can
just do that without having to have a
day job that that they don't like or
whatever there's a lot of people I know
that operating in that landscape where
they have some job that's kind of
interesting and they do it because you
know they have options like they could
you know there's nothing like work on
something that completely don't like a
whatever and although there are a lot of
people like that are in that position
but at the same time it's not what they
will they love the most and it's what
will pay their bills and in the same
time they're creating a ton of value by
working on a whole bunch of interesting
open source projects but there's no easy
way for them to get rewarded by the
value that's captured many many layers
deep after so my claim and this is a
complete you know guess and that could
be totally wrong about this but I claim
that if we solve that problem in a way
that we have a function like I could run
a function over all of the people on
github that have contributed to
all of the projects that protocol apps
runs and all of the projects that
protocol labs projects use so like we're
talking about not only the community
that's working on one project but also
the community other communities your
project depends on right like we depend
on things like the Linux kernel and so
can we figure out a way to correctly and
accurately propagate reward back in a
way that's fair and that correctly you
know gages a whole bunch of these hard
questions about opportunity cost okay
externality is playing at that have you
seen the papers about how to fairly
slice a cake yes
so essentially you slice and I pick
there's ways that they found a way to
extrapolate that into multiple parties
and so this isn't the actual solution
but I wonder if you could use where
other contributors all are slicing other
people's cake so that like they decide
proof of work well yeah so that's
intuition it's a good intuition but then
are you sure that's not game ax ball
because then I could just get a
collection of ten people that you know
we all like each other and we all give
each other a huge country huge slices
but that's how companies work oftentimes
right like there's someone who doesn't
always push the best code but they might
be a huge morale boost and so like then
being on the project is actually
supervisor yeah wait so to touch that
those are what you're looking for
something that doesn't use human
intervention whatsoever it's a purely
algorithmic answer I think it's fine to
feed in human intervention along the way
you know there's interesting research
done on large companies and governments
where you have all these you know peer
reviews and you know kind of like and
manager reviews and and all this kind of
you know 360 review counter perspective
and out of that you can get a good
signal right like otherwise if we didn't
we're getting good signal then there's
no hope for you before any kind of
companies that looks large right and so
surely something's working and there's
good research that shows like you can
definitely get interesting human
feedback on the in loop and you can take
out a signal but the hard thing is I
claim that what we need to do is is
allow the collection of that feedback to
have the humans in the loop but do so in
such a way that is extremely difficult
to game because you know again that's if
you if you get people quickl people will
quickly learn that they can just like
give each other really hydrating into
that will have the translate
really big boosts and promotions and so
on or like you know greater rewards you
have to get something that doesn't like
it's not easy to game but then further
if you take people out of the equation
in the choosing part at the very top
like all of those feedback all that
feedback always propagates all the way
to the top and it's ultimately people
making decisions that you know kind of
like compensation and all this kind of
stuff in this is in companies but in in
science it's like grant funding like the
people that actually choose who to give
grants to and what research to fund or
in open source it's like hey a company
decided to invest deeply into this
project because they thought it was like
super valuable and like the allocated
engineers to just work on that but like
they're not directly just giving money
to everyone in that project if we just
take humans how to loop in that decision
process and put an algorithm that people
can have confidence over that this is
going to be a correct and fair you know
a portion fair allocation of the reward
at least better than most humans would
do at first pass approximation if we can
do that turn that in turn algorithm then
I claim we could fix a whole bunch of
cap tables around the world that like
really screwed up and you can fix a
whole bunch of the way that grant
funding is done in in in science because
you're not going to rely as hard on on
prior success and you're not going to or
rather you're not going to rely as hard
on like social signals and you're going
to rely more on like deep achievement
and I claim you can do something
fundamentally new which is you can start
propagating rewards through open source
to the point where a lot of people can
gravitate to the things that they think
are extremely valuable and they you know
they invest their time instead of
investing their money into things that
they think are cool and interesting and
valuable and if those turn out to be
valuable in such a way that reward ends
up getting propagated back to them they
can then turn that contribution into
eating right like there's this we're
headed for like a very big economic
problem and we're already kind of in the
middle of it but we're going to have
bigger problems that ass automation
comes in AI comes in and all this kind
of stuff
it's got a challenger from our basic
notions of of worth in value in you know
economic terms right like we live in a
world that's centered very very rigidly
around the perspective of hey you have
you get a job and you work and you
contribute value to an endeavor and you
get back some pay and you turn that pay
into food and so if you want food and
shelter and survival and if you want
nice things and if you want to like be
able to like you know not only survive
and have good things and so on but like
you want to leave you know be able to
afford school for your kids or
healthcare and so on you have to have a
job and this job is mediated by you know
kind of like a whole bunch of external
forces and it prevents a ton of people
from allocating their work to what they
think is actually most fundamentally
valuable and I claim it doesn't do as
good of a job as it should in correctly
rewarding major contributions we see
people with noah prizes and turing
prizes that have made massive
contribution to the world and have you
know not net worths
similar to groups that like ended up
doing like terrible things for the
course and and managed to get away with
it right and so the claim here is one
that this on the small scale could
improve dramatically something like open
source and and potentially like
companies on how you allocate
composition there but in a big scale a
really good answer to this problem could
be a new economic model like it could be
like the a new version of capitalism or
it could be something else it's not
called capitalism
it could be something around like just
like correct M&O like it's a whole new
world right so I think it's that's super
interesting and we've had a lot of
discussions internally around basic
income I think yeah where I get hung up
on this is that let's pretend that we
did healthy hour let's pretend someone
to the research and they found a fair
way to allocate worth would anyone
accept it like essentially the tricky
part is not the technical challenge it's
getting people to ever believe a
computer is fair or ever like what if
the algorithm said actually you're not
worth very much you know how I like it's
very hard to imagine people saying you
know what you're right this this
algorithm is
hiren leaf but i think it actually like
meshes quite well with the American
mindset which is like I can do work and
create more value than the next person
rather than relying on some social
system around you you're like if I'll
just do it in like right now we rely on
the market to decide what's valuable but
who knows like yeah ideally so that's
where I think I mean I think for this to
work correctly you have to have markets
involved and you have to have this kind
of algorithm either working in a market
yeah you can turn an algorithm into a
market right and then ideally you
wouldn't have one one computer that like
decides what you're worth right but
rather you have an entire like
large-scale system and relative worth is
being ascribed by other groups where
like you have a lot of cases where one
group thinks something is really bad one
another group doesn't think so and
that's fine it's just like they have
they themselves are occurring value and
worth in whatever ways and they can
propagate it or however they want you
know similar to like you know companies
going in opposite directions or whatever
and yes it's going to call into question
a bunch of hard things as like you know
here's like your what your contribution
is really worth but my claim is right
now we we have in much work this is kind
of I kind of describe this is similar to
the self-driving car problem people
think how could a computer ever possibly
drive better than me like computers are
stupid right and I am a great driver and
I can go fast and I can react really
well and so on I would never trust a
computer and yet you know it's taking a
long time it's taken in over 50 years
this is like the first plans to do this
up here but now we have computers that
write better than humans and pretty soon
they're going to start getting deployed
and we're going to start writing in them
and so on and people will see that this
is this is going to save us out of lives
compared comparatively and so my claim
is is you can create something that's
fair and you can create something that
it's also provably her so one of the
things here about algorithms is you can
have a computational screwable that
actually runs over the whole thing and
can produce a cryptographically
verifiable proof that it was done
correctly and like that was correctly
assigning the right thing and it could
give you a trace of like all of the
violation and like here's here's the
argument as to why this determination
was made and and I think like that would
be a much better place to be than where
we are now where it's extremely fuzzy
it's extremely like
based on a whole bunch of factors that I
think you know our bias is all over the
place and and allow you know a few
people that understand all of those
biases and perspectives to then game
them and then put themselves in
positions of greater and greater greater
power which is by the way I think one of
the big reasons why capital accumulates
there's a whole bunch of reasons why
capital accumulates and centralizes but
I think one of them is the fact that
like once you understand enough about
how all this stuff works
you can then position yourself on
maneuver yourself to expose yourselves
to things that that generated a lot of
capital and wealth that don't
necessarily generate or create a lot of
value right there's a very big
difference between capital and value
that is not correctly on like the value
of a dollar today does not equate to
like just raw fundamental value right
and so we use an approximation and we
think that it's a good enough
approximation that continue using it but
in a lot of ways you can see things that
are worth massive amounts of money
there's tons of companies I'd like to
get a lot of value by like dumping a
bunch of crap into the ocean and like
wrecking you know there's a whole bunch
of externalities that we cannot properly
calculate and account in those in those
situations and ultimately there's at
least in in most countries in here in in
the world you have groups of people that
are making those decisions at the very
top and deciding what are the outcomes
of major bad actors like actors that
have made serious mistakes like you know
the 2008 crisis like major mistakes and
they seem like well yeah all these were
major mistakes all of these things
should fail but if they fail we're going
to be in deeper trouble so let's just
bail them out and continue as if nothing
has happened to some degree not quite
but to some degree and a ton of the
people walked away scot-free right like
and got away with in made in some cases
it actually making money through the
financial crisis in you know people that
were directly responsible for the
problem ended up with returns and like
this is like screwed up right now I
think like this is something extremely
far away for my correct and fair
distribution of value and and and you
know and so I think you know that's I
think an open problem of the kind of
like pre companies for pre capitalism or
this kind of thing like if we find a
good solution to this problem it could
in decades translate into every wiring
of how we how we say
and how we how we value things on how we
allocate resources and all that in the
small scale I think that we were
beginning to see a few experiments in
the direction I see things like whether
theorem was able to do with its own
resources and in being able to like just
give a lot of people ether then accrued
in value and so on and do things kind of
like through RFPs and try to like get
some vague matter of like what this
might be worth and giving people a share
of the return not not dollars or Euros
right but like instead ether which means
it's a share of the potential future
value generated by the network its art
is a step in the right direction in its
like if we're going to grade in the
center way into this right but like you
know so step in the right direction and
I think we are gearing up to try some
things like this so do you think the way
if you've looked at the relative
distribution of wealth from crypto that
that is a good model because there isn't
it really concentrate on a small number
of people that happen to have the
resources to be early um so I don't
think that I think a few people ended up
getting a lot of value also with a lot
of these projects a few people ended up
creating massive amounts of that value I
think like you know for example I think
people should not at all undervalue the
italics contribution I think you can
trigger an enormous amount to to the
entire space and I use that as an
example there's probably a whole bunch
of misallocations over the place like
you can probably find because I'm just
thinking through you were saying about
but but I also know a lot of people like
indie dozens to hundreds that made a lot
of money through crypto who slog through
the creation of value in this new
network who understood the value of this
thing were willing to take the risk and
work on it and you know really spent you
know the better part of a year and a
half like working on something that was
completely you know super high risk
unclear that was going to work out and
so on and they've seen returns that are
higher than most startups like higher
than than what their distribution would
have been in red and so like a 400x
return right but if you bought each area
method crowd feelings when you go then
well I mean think conversely think of it
like you just happen to you know luck
into being one of the first 10 employees
at a giant company of the 25th person is
the person who actually created the
value and their allocation is much less
than yours yes like that model is not
figured out yet I am I'm deeply like
frustrated by that problem I desperately
want to fix that problem and I think
that if we fix our problem then we can
have massively open into the creation of
value in a strong claim but like I think
like fixing that it makes sense would
make otama tech companies work extremely
well and be able to generate tons of
value and not only tech companies with
tech projects in general like the
company is fading away and or not anyway
but rather a new thing is has come in
which is a network or a market that that
is not a company but it functions kind
of like a company and so you can think
of a theorem not as a company but rather
as a this network that that has some
shared asset that is that is incenting
people to work on it and so on and
there's like some loose organization but
not not really centralized or it's not
really central planning and like that's
a whole bunch of things that are
interesting and are pushing in the right
direction and I would say that the
distribution of wealth is probably
flatter I don't know this to be a
hundred percent of the case and then any
to look at the the raw data but I think
the raw data for Bitcoin of years ago
wasn't pretty awesome I looked at it for
what it's worth
yeah what about it here I don't I don't
actually know I haven't seen any
breakdowns on that but I remember I was
actually very curious about this about
not like not what Satoshi has but like
the other people the head some people
that bought an early basically likely
like what is there a relative
distribution and yeah yeah I'm kind of
bothered by that I'm kind of bothered by
the fact that in crypto right now you're
seeing the normal issues with capital
flood in which is that if you're a
specular that has a lot of capital you
can afford to get much greater rewards
than the people that actually build the
thing and and that to me is again
another frustrating thing that is why
this is why I ask because it's like here
we are we're creating all this new stuff
it's incremental right okay I think it's
a step in the right direction and a big
step there I say quantum leap in the
right direction and I think it's what's
interesting to me is rather what has not
what has been done so far but the tools
we now have
meaning that and this is starting to get
into the experiments we're going to run
next year and the year after that but
we're looking at the possibilities of
issuing a token to a whole bunch of
contributors that have created a whole
bunch of value to you know a ton of
projects that we think are valuable
mostly look right now we're going to do
them with our own projects but you know
if this works well we could do the you
know we can do that in even deeper way
across projects that contribute value to
us and we're going to issue this token
and then we either are going to do
things like issue dividends or buyback
and create a way for us to directly
share a fraction of the value that
Farrokh labs creates with the people
that helped make create a value and it
is a huge experiment right you can go
completely wrong it could change the way
that people why people contributed it
could like bring in a lot of people that
are not deeply interested in the right
things and are kind of just looking for
money and like that's what I worry about
I don't want to do anything that like
what would cause that because I think
open source like it's an amazing place
where people are motivated to to work
for the projects because of what you
believe in and like that's super
important like yeah I would hate it if
whatever kind of experiment in this
direction
kills the fact that the Linux kernel is
build by applying to people that really
cared deeply about the problems and are
fixing them and so like it has to be
done carefully but I think we can start
running some experiments right because
you don't want every project to end up
at some weird local maximum we're like
okay companies are using this now value
will accrue to me I can jump to the next
thing okay so is this being wrapped into
coin list yet like these ideas ah
so I mean they are ideas we are thinking
about these are not being wrapped into
into coin lists or other things just yet
you know there's a lot of things that we
have to carefully consider - I mean the
thing about intent of engineering is
that it's hard I mean this is why this
problem is an open problem and you know
I you know if you're listening to this
and you're researcher and you care about
this like get in touch
because I'm probably going to start a
small like research group to to to solve
this problem but I don't expected as a
successful thing in years like I think
this is a long term thing I think this
is this is like a the kind of research
project that protocol apps could fund
that is one of those long term
innovation things and we actually don't
think we need that many people I think
like probably the right 10 people can
solve it wrong maybe even less maybe
it's like a singular person that like
actually figures it out with as has
happened in a ton of other cases in
history but I think we can start at the
very least collecting some data to
assist the theory and that data that
might come with some of these
experiments and we are thinking about
the significance I mostly want a reward
right now I mostly want to reward a lot
of the people that were very early to
the I profess project that saw the value
created and said wow this is an awesome
project and we want to make this you
know a reality and and so on
and you know we've been slogging through
a ton of hard work for the last three
years we're like it right now I guess go
at the FS turn three years old yet like
two days ago
the protocol itself is a little bit
older but um that would like you know
the code base and there's a ton of
people that came in and helped out
tremendously some of them who you know
didn't make sense for us to hire into
protocol labs some of the people like
for whatever reason some of those cases
are like academics some of them are like
grass students and professors who talk
with me and walk me through certain
important things that end up
contributing value to the project and
and I want to find a way to then divert
some of the return that we'll see from
from foul point because what we're going
to do it like we're going to create this
whole path or network and I will
generate a ton of value and and a whole
bunch of people like the miners in the
park network they're going to get a ton
of a ton of value and so what product
labs and then can we divert some of that
value that protocol apps gets back and
and pump it straight into all of the
open source work that we do in a way
that doesn't like hurt hurt it right
like I'm very very wary and careful
about anywhere where money and open
source gets mixed because it can get
like really screwed up
and it can come like kill project but I
think that things like etherium are
examples
things being done better and right in
some direction and at least in in a
successful one right like you can look
at the theorem community and it's filled
with researchers like like people who
are thinking deep and hard about theory
and the correct application and of what
you know think people are thinking about
consensus and consensus problems like
the kind of stuff that only Turing Award
winners normally think about right like
or you know grad students that are
trying to like up end like 20 years of
research or whatever and like there's
people in the theorem community actually
doing this work and it's amazing like
it's like it should not be undervalued
like that's I it's extremely difficult
to find communities where not only is
that valued by everyone around but it's
also greatly rewarded right and like
that that's I think is an example in the
right direction and I think one that we
can we can build on and create more of
and if this gets to be you know I think
it's etherium and popcorn and these
networks got to be massive and end up
like being at the same degree and scale
as a whole bunch of the other other ways
of doing things like the the centralized
tech companies and so on then we can
then start looking at rewarding people
across company lines so here's an
addition problem right like there's a
ton of people that work at Google and
some of people that work upon to the
other places that could contribute
massively to these projects by just
spending a few hours maybe on a week or
later on and they're the right people
that have the right insights that have
the right perspective and right now they
can't work for another company because
it's like a conflict of interest
but they can contribute to open source
now like in many cases they do and then
reward can be back propagated in a weird
way right and so like it's it's a people
contribute and then later a value gets
created then there's like this backdrop
that happens out of like distributions
of the token and so I don't know how
that works with like or how that's going
to turn out and work with IP and so on
but I think it's kind of conveying kind
of like a wrecking ball in that a ton of
a ton of I know a lot of researchers
that encrypts on game theory and so on
that understood the crypto world and
then either got a bunch of Bitcoin or
ether and now can just chill out and be
accidents or professors in some cases
and just do the research they really
care about and they're not personally
wealthy and it's awesome like that's
fantastic like that that is a great
example of a correct application of the
reward problem like right there like the
people that generated massive amount of
value by slogging through really hard
teary problems for years and came up
with a right solution and so on are now
able to like correctly make
contributions in some cases like short
time signed contributions again
knowledge work is really hard to measure
in hours you can't you can't measure
knowledge working hours
somebody's investment over a decade can
put them into the right perspective to
make the right contribution at the right
time that creates something like a
theorem or Bitcoin or whatever and you
know how do you correctly reward that
and the things like something like like
these cryptic currency networks can
reward that better than the normal
notion of of like yearly pay in a
salaried thing that was built for the
Industrial Revolution where like you
needed manufacturing and you need to
just build for hours because like you
had to spend a whole bunch of hours
working on something right
and so thinking like this is an
interesting thing and I think we're
starting to see this this develop and
you know we're like thinking about
things like that like how do we build
vertical ABS an organization that can do
deep research a bunch of different
directions with a bunch of collaborators
around the planet in a bunch of
different organizations and how can we
structure things in such a way that if
those things we collaborate on succeed
greatly
everyone gets rewarded everyone who
contributed to that thing gets rewarded
fairly like that's you know super hard
to to try and solve but you know we want
to want to do that so I think this is a
good place to pause so you get a roll we
do have some questions from Twitter so
that would be awesome to address cool
all right let's we can just bus thank
you thank let's go into the Twitter
questions we got a handful you can
answer them however you'd like so from
start up Sanatana how does file coins
data storage network how is it natural /
unnatural disaster-proof a great
question so it really depends on on the
scale of the natural disaster I mean
like if a comment hit the planet that's
a little hard but sort of pieces here
one of them is IP
is by nature what I like to call it
fully distributed or logically
decentralized italic allsup which is
that the the nodes in the exercise
network and continue talking to each
other even if the rest of the network
disappears and so file coin because it
used ipfs and so on
thought the nodes will be able to talk
to each other even if they can't talk to
the rest of the network now there's a
question they're like how can you clear
transactions and like that that's the
thing that we have active and deep
research on we want to have a network
that can shard and where you can have a
subset of the path or network operating
even if it can't talk to the rest of
network and clear transactions to the
heart problem the first iteration of of
the talk and I where that goes live
won't quite do that but the way it'll be
in so there's like you know if you get
isolated from the wrestle Network you
you may not be able to clear
transactions but you might be able to
distribute files up where at least for
some period of time and then if you are
in the rest of network but then like how
it disappears because of some huge
natural disaster I guess slightly less
than 1/2 + n / 2 we can survive those
failures because when people add data to
the network it gets split up into pieces
get erasure coded so you can get like
this really nice replication factor
where without adding too much overhead
we're like the replication factor does
not add massive overhead you can get a
huge resilience factor where you know
you can you can survive huge numbers of
failures and your data can still be
there the exact numbers on this like
will will come up with and publish the
exact details on those down the road but
it's going to get tunable parameter so
you can like crank up the the level of
erasure coded as effectively that you
want and only you have a set on the user
side yeah so if you have a megabyte of
data that's really important you just
like crank up the replication factor and
like the you know that originally
splitting into pieces and erasure coding
so that you have like hundreds of these
and like now you and they go all go out
to a whole bunch of different miners and
so now you are in a much better position
than then if you know only three people
were like we're storing this set gets
one one photo in circa a next question
Robert Andrew Smith
when will file coin sale details be
released and then following up on that
yes files going sale details will be
released very soon unfortunately we
can't give you give an exact date but
it's it's weeks away it's like you know
it's sometime in the next few weeks very
soon we are working as far as we can
right now to get it out of door there's
the reason for for that though we can't
announce an exact date yet is that we
there are a few like things especially
on around there's a couple of processes
that are running right now that we have
kind of like a date that they were going
to finish and that's ideally a week or
two weeks out but if there's a little
bit of unpredictability yet there so I
want to be able to do the sale as soon
as possible but you know subject to that
so really like weeks but expect news
very very soon then he also asked
another question what other plans do you
have with coin list so coin list which
is another project that that protocol
app started this is a and this is an
internship with angellist and this is a
token sale platform that kind of will
allow token project creators to launch
their networks and run token sales
without having to slog through the
hundreds of hours that we spent both
building this kind of platform and going
to legal and so on and pointless works
with the shaft it colas will have we
worked with a lot of sales that are both
include assassins others don't but
basically like there's this important
piece that if you want to run a token
sale in the US you want to there's like
a question there around whether or not
you're selling a security and if you if
you think you're indeed selling a
security then you should limit it limit
the sale of that security to accredited
investors at least in the US and when
you when you do that then Cornelis makes
that easy and you can accredit in the
same way that you would accredit to
through AngelList but you know that does
not even like the main selling point
Aquinas the main selling point of course
will be decreasing the amount of work
for token co-creators and creating a
network that is that focuses on finding
really high signal projects right so
there's a ton of projects in the space
and the one of the things that we care a
lot about is how do you how do you find
really really good projects and and help
those gain attention and kind of like
stick out and and how can you help them
prove it right like it's one thing for
that project to kind of like convey a
lot of things but it becomes really
useful when you have third parties that
are independent think about those
projects and and and kind of have fun
yeah we're very interested in solving
that signal problem how do you how do
you correctly figure out what other
really solid and outstanding projects
and so we think that's going to be an
important value proposition from Coyle i
stuff like really finding the best
things around that those aren't really a
question I wanted to ask before but
didn't do you have any rules of thumb
that you can give to people around like
filtering out all the noise right now
yeah so we've got a you know a ton of
applications and it's a lot of
interesting stuff is it's coming down
the pipeline some live really really
cool stuff
we've also seen you know some some scams
like we we've actually like seen some
applications that are like outright
outright scams I think you know we don't
want to be in a position of being like
effectively gatekeepers that prevent
really good ideas from from if we don't
understand something we shouldn't be
kind of like gay people gay keepers that
we have to convince but on the flip side
we also don't want things that we can
tell are outright scams on a platform
and we want at least you know some layer
of like barriers there to make sure that
the projects that do get listed on coin
list pass a certain bar of quality now
there could be some very cleverly
engineered and designed scams or
whatever that that fool even us or
whatever so you know anyone investing
through any kind of a management
platform it's ultimately you know
responsible for doing their own
diligence but at the very least we're
going to think cut out a huge fraction
of a lot of those things and we're
working on ways of
helping project creators highlight their
technical strengths and their you know
the the create the value they propose in
ways that like let them shine against
other projects that could probably spend
a whole bunch of money on marketing and
so on but actually really have no
important technical depth underneath the
hood and so that's a whole bunch of
interesting problems that we want to we
want to help stop the process okay
and obviously accredited investors it's
a major part of that yeah yeah and I
think a Korean investor is kind of
weighing in on things it's an important
part although I would say you know I
think this is an important piece or
we're gonna have the message is better
in that not all sales that will go
through points are going to be only for
credit investors there will be some
sales that are not securities and then
you know people can can buy normally and
there also will be the case that some
sales might want to do our reg reg D 506
C offering in the u.s. so that's
accredited investors only but are able
to do a reg S funding to the rest of the
world and do and figure out things
outside so this is kind of similar to
what blocking capital did so we're
looking deeply into that and we want to
lend up we want to we we expect that
number of tokens we'll be able to do
that I can't definitively say that they
will certainly be able to do that
because there's some thousand legal
questions there that we need to solve
and additionally we want to involve
crowdfunding as well we think that it's
very important that people in the US
that are not accredited
but that understand the tech really well
and are able to make investments like
that it's just the the burden on on
doing crowdfunding is quite quite large
and there's you know those questions is
like how does that combine with your
currency and so on that you know we are
doing the legal review on and legal work
on at the moment and we hope to have
news on that relatively soon but we that
stuff that we are actively working on
and trying to enable because we don't
want the accredited investor limit to
you know prevent people that truly
understand the tech and perhaps are much
better investors than accredited
investors being like you know having a
million dollars does not mean that you
know
what cryptocurrencies Network is going
to be-better or what your paternal II
will work there were a lot of people
investing things that had a lot of money
and could lose it on things that didn't
work out and a lot of people that
understood that something like a theorem
was gonna be really valuable so we want
to we want to enable people to come into
these things like this and so we're
looking at crowdfunding we're also
looking at other ways of potentially
involving people that you know for
whatever reason they can't directly
invest in the presale but maybe we're
perhaps they can they can come in when
the token goes live in an actual token
sale broader in in like live exchanges
at a discount at some sort of discount
that that puts them into it in a good
position but it's like sometimes that
can be done by instead of it coming in
and investing early rather helping the
network right so one of the big parts of
get gathering investors to network like
this is is gathering people that are
really well aligned with the network and
want to help it grow and like that's
that's what investors should be
investors should not be just like random
speculators that like are just trying to
make a quick buck we are interested in
helping create large-scale communities
that have like really strong buy-in from
people that want to you know help create
them and you know see the promise and so
one of the things that we're talking
about like okay great like there's a lot
of people that you know maybe are
unfortunately limited by the laws around
accreditation however they probably have
the ability to get in law actually
involved directly with the projects and
contributing in another way that would
then you know in a sounds like they they
could get rewarded by either getting
they're getting paid for their work in
in tokens or or potentially being able
to buy the token when it comes out at a
discount that they have that other
people don't have that's a good point I
hadn't heard about that okay Jesse
jump-cut asks I'm having trouble
understanding the market need for file
coin is storage a burning pain that
consumers face oh definitely I mean all
you have to think about is how much data
is being generated by computers right so
so this is not just for for consumers
although consumers do have a lot of data
like think about you know I have a phone
here and like how much I don't even know
how much service this has but it has a
lot and I use a lot of a lot of data by
having applications that you know
download video or whatever or you know
when you take pictures and video and so
on people's like the right way to answer
this question is look at the growth in
market of cloud storage and it's growing
tremendously and so cloud storage in
general is the idea of reselling storage
for other other groups and consumers
massive business and so on are seeing
exponential growth in data so data and
the need to story this about one of the
few things you can look at and say this
is growing exponentially and shows no
sign of stopping anytime soon and so you
kind of have to extrapolate like our
humans going to continue like for the
freighting and building more cities and
replicate I think I would really Graham
yes and like we need a lot more data
yeah but I think I would reframe the
question actually like what is
differentiated with file coin to like
you know fat box like why do I care
about using it totally and I mean
Falcone is not to be seen as a drop box
replacement although there will be drop
box like things that build on build on
top of point I think you should think
about Falcone as as replacing cloud
storage so it's something that Dropbox
would use so so a company like Dropbox
should would think about like oh do we
run our own managed infrastructure or do
we use AWS or do we use something like
five point and so that's where the the
economic improvement comes with like it
was what is the relative advantage of
something like file going to other cloud
storage offerings in a sense and the
thing here is there's a certain set of
features that fat one will bring that
other things don't have so being able to
have decentralized data means that you
know if Amazon doesn't like you anymore
they can't like just in one turn shut
you off in a way that like suddenly you
have to like move to another provider
and you have to deal with like changing
all of your address and everything like
right now with Bocconi would be work
continue it will continue to work and to
it's about so there's a whole bunch of
features like that and arrays your
coding and so on that we keep going to
and there's a whole bunch of other
things around the market dynamics in
general in that file point is not you
shouldn't think about one is like
another provider think about power point
as a market
so some five-point is a market layers
across all providers and enables a whole
bunch of providers that right now are
not selling data in the world to come in
and sell it so think about how much
storage there is on the planet that
right now is not being sold to other
people and that if that storage came
online it would drive the price down in
the storage that right now is
depreciating a lot of people have
invested huge amount of money in having
massive arrays of hard drives that are
not giving them any money and you know
losing money on those investments and to
think about creating a market that
enables anybody to then sell all that
storage to the rest of the world and
make a you know for profit and you know
there's a whole bunch of questions that
are like wow can you really achieve you
know economies of scale with a network
like this can you really you know get a
better unit economics of like can you
can you provide bytes cheaper than
something like Google cloud or Amazon or
whatever and our bet there is that yes
that there's a whole bunch of places and
cases where certain individuals or
groups in the world have access to
either really cheap storage or storage
that's positioned well in the network
that is kind of like you know somewhere
between the backbone and like a whole
bunch of consumers and if they become
falkland miners and search nodes they
could actually be in a better
optimization point than even something
like Amazon and so that's you know
that's the bet and we think it's it's
right and like that on its own is like
an interesting interesting reason for
people to opt in to something like five
coin and and so yeah I think about it
kind of like an algorithmic market say
instead of this having a very
inefficient market where you have to
when you want a higher storage you have
to go and like research companies and
you have to look at them and you have to
like sign up with them and create you
know you have to be a legal entity you
have to be either a person or a company
and or whatever like you have to like
have a credit card and it's like by you
know you enter into some legal
agreements and then you enter into legal
agreement then you can send the bytes
like this huge onerous process and when
you compare them you like see their
websites and so on to something closer
to Lex
like spot market where any file any
storage that's available worldwide but
that has shown to have good metrics and
you shown to be online for the long
period of time shown to be good or
whatever can then be sold to you at the
cheapest possible price that you can you
want
immediately algorithmically right like
and so this is about changing the market
completely it's going from a world of
like centralized source providers to a
world where like there's a huge market
and it's mediated programmatically
mm-hmm okay so adding on to that same
person Jesse jump-cut had another
question how does file Coyne plan to
compete with companies like SIA and
storage I don't know yeah who have been
out for a while
so I think you know there's totally and
in you know there's a few things there
one is the the recent fact one is not
out yet is because we spend a ton of our
time building the I profess project and
getting that out of the door and there's
a ton of people that are using the I
profess projects that are you know want
desperately one-pot going to be out and
like we know that already we have a ton
of users lined up that right now are not
going to those those other competitors
they're actually like either in s3 or
other places and you know would jump
directly to us and then the deeper
question and way to look at it is just
think about the technology and we're
about to release like the second version
over of our over protocol and it's just
a fundamentally different thing like it
operates in a different way it offers
different guarantees and so on and we
think that those different guarantees or
actually have a very significant market
need and solve a whole bunch of
different market needs then these other
networks don't and so that's like kind
of like how we're going to be able to
compete another thing is and and this is
you know I don't know how how it'll play
out but I actually bet a lot of people
will be mining on both networks or like
all the networks and we'll see how that
actually plays out and then we'll see
kind of like right now there's a lot of
drivers striving for either uber or lyft
and we think the the tokens and like the
rewards and tokens will be a and
people's expectations and like unlike
Kalos will will end up working will kind
of drive to my people to mine in one so
like I guess an addition question right
now would be did people switch from
storage to
SIA SIA when the SIA coin appreciated a
lot right that's doesn't in some
questions that people should look into
can I cross this storage so with in some
ways you will be able to in other ways
you won't so so it's actually like it is
very protocol dependent and different
verticals a lot of different ways some
some of the things you won't be able to
cross this some of the things you will
be able to cross list and so there will
be some kind of like there people will
try and get trying to game it a little
bit yeah I mean like I mean people are
participating to different networks I
mean like they're storing data so
because of the proof of replication when
when you have proof replication backed
storage that that ensures that it is
unique to this particular request and
that's very important same for my game
theory perspective like you don't want
people you don't want like networks of
stables basically pretending to be
storing huge amounts of data when
they're only storing like one copy like
the thing is not replicated so that's
what the perfect replication is
therefore and so some things you won't
be able to across this but some things
like for fast retrieval and so on like
those those are we cross the scible and
but I think like answering the question
in like a deeper ways it's like I think
I look at path line of something very
different in these other networks it's
not solving exactly the same problem if
I'm still thinking the problem of like
how do you create a market and allow any
provider so there's actually a
possibility where SIA and storage make
sense
as you know route route content to them
because if those networks provide kind
of like a tiered structure okay
we'll see what happens this one is a
little bit in the weeds so this is a
user holy Nakamoto referenced a github
issue from a couple years ago oh man
yeah I don't know if you remember this
one so is the idea of ipfs rendering
DDoS attacks impossible hyperbole oh
well it depends on how you this is not
hyperbole in the whole sense there are
some ways and you can take that question
LTS prevention and say oh well no you
can't possibly mitigate all possible
DDoS attacks on something but the way to
think about access is that
when you have a piece of content once
you have the piece of content or anybody
else around in the network has it you
can retrieve it from them and it doesn't
have to come from the original source so
we've already seen cases where people
you know can das a specific location and
like it can das a URL that that some
resource is that but if it's a it's a
name that you know you you know some
providers that have that content and you
can reach them but the das attackers
can't know who those providers are for a
whole bunch of there could be a lot of
reasons for this it could be like
they're actually disconnected you're in
a network that they're not connected to
or you have access to a like a network
where you have the ability to search
through a whole bunch of nodes that are
willing to share routing information
with you but are unwilling to open it
broadly to the whole world this is this
is kind of like a this.get starts
getting into private networks like when
people people are building private ipfs
networks where they have their own set
of content that is not as opposed to the
rest of the world and so for example
you're going to be able to like search
through through some networks like that
and like right there alone like you have
like entire barriers where where people
like the doctors that can't even get to
the content first of all what I can't
get to the machines that are serving it
so that solves it the other case is hey
like if there's some really popular
piece of content and something gets
replicated to tons of people now the DOS
attack gets way harder right like now
now you have to does thousands of people
and so it's not it's not fundamentally
in that particular case it's not that
it's impossible it becomes intractable
so because intractable work for it for
even a sophisticated attacker to das all
possible computers that that have this
piece of content so this will be
especially with like really you know
incendiary things that a lot of people
want to replicate think about like
WikiLeaks type stuff a lot of people
want to replicate it all over the place
and then very quickly will become very
difficult for an attacker to actually
silence all possible machines and so it
is not hyperbole
it is impossible in some cases and then
intractable in others ok cool that's a
good answer
next question Erik Tang asks where do
you see is the most immediate industry
slash text
stack slash use case
for being decentralized so what are the
basically a way to reframe that question
is where is it valuable to have the
centralization I think he's kind of
leaning towards like what is a product
or use case for something like something
you know built on a CRM to be top
centralized in that way
yeah I mean I think maybe this ipfs it
would be a better answer
oh yeah well - I think the
centralization changes the properties of
the infrastructure and it shouldn't be a
thing that the end-user should have to
care about in a lot of cases some users
will care about care about it but I
think it's not something that they
should have to care about meaning that
developers are the ones that should
think about whether this intuition
matters and that has to do a lot with
the again specific use cases and
specific applications that you're
dealing with when I look at things like
slack or github or Google Docs that are
consumer applications that people use
daily to do their work and talk to their
co-workers or loved ones or you know
things like messengers and so on and all
of that flow of information is passing
through a set of centralized agents that
can be brought down and frequently are
brought down you know there's like a lot
of cases where github does go down or
slack does go down or your connection to
them gets severed in some way look you
just can't reach them like maybe you're
offline or whatever that is a great
example where like logical
centralization sucks
we're like the fact that you can't reach
that virgin server like prevents you
from using any of the data or working
together or whatever and it gets so bad
that you could have a room full of
people with laptops open on flack or on
a Google Doc and they can't work
together because they're super computers
which I again like let's be clear here
like these computers are more powerful
than like all of the all of the
computers on the planet we're like you
know a few decades ago there are super
computers that they have in front of
them can't figure out the content
they're on an application they want to
run is really between them
and the ones right next to each other
and our piping all of the data flows
straight up the up the uplink straight
into the data center and then back and
that's just stupid like it wrong and we
should not live in that world and so I
want to live in a world where if you
have a computer and you're trying to
work with somebody across from you the
data can flow from one person to another
and you can continue working whether or
not some random machine somewhere else
in the world is failing so yeah it sort
of answer the question like literally
anything where like interacting between
people yeah it's an infrastructure thing
it's like there's a whole bunch of cases
where where it's like the underlying you
have you want to think about how the
underlying data flows move and answering
the question for like the etherium case
it's really about power it's like where
do you want people to be able to exert
power and like doing a transaction
through etherium and happening a smart
contract allows you to cut out trust and
power all over the place and have a very
clear thing that people agree to that is
enforced by a computer not by courts
that are slow and expensive and I think
with a lot of these things like you
don't necessarily have to make it
obvious to the end-user that this is
what you're doing
it just works it's better so Eric ask
one more question around
decentralization so where and how does
decentralization gain advantage over
centralized benefits where you think
about scale and cost so so where does it
where do the centralization benefits
actually provide better eunuch unit
economics in a way like where your costs
for providing the service are actually
better so I think this is where you want
to think about like having effective of
an optimization process you can get like
providing cheap storage to the world or
cheap distribution of content to the
world is a huge optimization problem
right like you're dealing with you know
billions of computers in the rounded
planet that are all trying to store or
retrieve content and a whole bunch of
places where you can store it and move
it and then you are dealing with again
billions of people that are using those
computers and that some subset of those
billions of people could actually work
on on maintaining that I work in some
some of them are going to be consumers
and so it turns it into like a super
complex optimization problem and the
point is
it's actually quite difficult for a
centrally planned organization to
correctly find all onyx and like use and
leverage all possible like you know
local minima in a bunch of places where
like this is exactly the right place
where you want to store something or
distribute it from and so on and get
like the best costs the best cost
reduction and so that's that's I think
where decentralization has a massive
advantage over centralized services
where like you're literally enabling any
person in the world who says oh I have a
clearer idea of how I can get cheap
power cheap connectivity cheap storage
cheap disk whatever and enabling them to
bring in and create a service right and
so it's kind of like I get some deeper
way to look at it is do you think
markets are more efficient or do you
think central planning is more efficient
and there's a lot of you know looking at
this question kind of naively it's like
well you know it like the naive answer
is like well markets are better and
because you know central planning is
that and the the slightly deeper answer
is well no if you had like a you know
massive computer that it's able to
actually calculate everything correctly
then you could actually solve that and
you could have you know correct
allocation of resources by just with one
program but then the even deeper version
of that is not all agents are similarly
incented which means that one agents
might produce an answer that it doesn't
is not actually optimal to everyone it's
optimal to that agent and so markets are
kind of fundamental in how we operate
and so markets allow individual actors
to you know
leverage optimizations and so like
that's that's a thing and those are
premises might not be optimizations for
somebody else and so that that's I think
we're like decentralization enough power
is really important to these networks in
that like the centralization of power
and choice of how to run the service
affects the kind of optimizations that
people may want to do and so on right so
a great example of is I know of a lot of
Bitcoin mines that have super cheap
power and they're able to get super to
power because they're in a particular
country where they were able to get a
certain deal or because they know the
right people or whatever and there's a
whole bunch of reasons why they suddenly
have much better unit economics that
then a major player would have
and you know they don't have enough
power that they could service everyone
in the world but they could you know at
least contribute that piece and if you
if you collect a whole bunch of these
pieces you actually can build a
large-scale service and so that's the
that's the I guess one of the insights
last question what other projects should
people be paying attention to right now
oh wow that is a great question I think
I mean man like this there's a ton of
interesting stuff like I think I'll
rattle up a few a few names I think
definitely a lot that people already
know about you know of course I think if
people don't yet understand how the
etherium works or and all that like
definitely dive in it's like the best
interaction - to the to the future I
guess
then then Bitcoin ever was or the kind
of stuff so definitely like dive into
all of that world definitely look at
things like open Bazaar and you know
whole bunch of applications that are
being built with with these new kinds of
networks you know things like Z cache
and so on that like bring in a new
property into the world and then start
looking at like if we want to think
about like new and more earlier things
there's a whole bunch of like
interesting developments around these
networks like there's a lot of people
building on aetherium there's like zero
X which is a decentralized exchange
there is life peer which is like a
peer-to-peer distribution thing that
will be be interacting with that that
aligns really well with a lot of VIP
plastic and the etherium tech there are
things like pesos which are like which
is a project to build a smart contracts
platform that is where the smart
contracts are written in El camel and
you have a lot more certainty about like
the the programming language property
like the properties of the programs
ideally would like to get to a point
where like everything is provable that's
probably unfeasible and you know
probably the right argument why you
can't do that and actually have a useful
thing but maybe there's something there
where like a a network could have like
everything be be provable and still be
really useful for a certain class of
computation
then numr is actually super interesting
so numr is a a hedge fund run with that
kind of decentralizes the the data
modeling so the predictive power of the
models is a centralized so like
individual participants can come in and
contribute different algorithms to try
and and leverage the hedge funds data to
trade better and so like that I think is
a very interesting mixing of both
competition between the those
participants are coming in but also
collaborate collaboration in that all of
them together are going to win together
memorize using a token and so I think
those are you know a set of projects
that are that are pretty interesting
this really like further out sayings
that are that are going to come out I
think I would if you're into research I
would HIGHLY encourage you follow the
proof of stake line of work we're
getting ever and ever closer and I think
we're quite close to something that can
succeed and work at scale there's
already several provable protocols so
anyway that's some some interesting
stuff this was great all right thanks
fun yeah thank you thank so much in
writing
you